so after two by-election defeats are the
wheels coming off the johnson bus
the housing secretary robert generic
will be with us in a moment
shadow chancellor rachel reeves on why
labor thinks they're
back on the road to number 10.
northern ireland's democratic unionist
parties had some trouble deciding who
should be at the wheel in recent times
but in his first television interview
since becoming leader
sir jeffrey donaldson tells our senior
ireland correspondent
david blevins how he sees the way ahead
plus i'll ask adam finn who's a member
of the joint committee on vaccination at
immunization
if we're still cruising towards the
easing of lockdown on july the 19th
and a broadcast exclusive the veteran
american pollster frank
luntz on a new survey of the
electorate's mood
there may be trouble ahead
but first the housing secretary robert
generic joins me
mr generic the new health secretary says
in an article this morning
that we have to learn to accept the
existence of covid
just as we do with the flu now according
to the
office for national statistics uh there
are some 20 000
deaths associated with flu in a typical
year are we now saying
that that annual toll with covid
is inevitable hi well good morning
trevor
i think we are now reaching a different
phase in the virus
we're not going to put the covert 19
virus behind us forever we're going to
have to learn
to live with it but thanks to the
enormous success of our vaccine
program the fact that now we've got to
the point where 83
of adults in this country have had at
least one jab
we should be able to think about how we
can return
to normality as much as possible and the
data that we're seeing that the prime
minister is reviewing
at the moment ahead of his decision
point on the roadmap
looks very positive it does seem as if
we can now move forward and move to a
much more permissive
regime where we move away from many of
those restrictions that have been so
difficult for us
and as you say learn to live with the
virus
that does mean that we're going to have
to treat it
carefully we're going to have to keep on
monitoring the cases
and we're going to have to ensure that
every adult gets double vaxxed
because that is the key to keeping the
virus under control as we move into the
autumn
and the winter that's admirably clear
and
it looks as though you are following the
prime minister's
suggestion that um we will be put
lifting the restrictions but the bma the
british medical
association is urging caution for
example keeping the requirement for face
masks in public places
now um mr general will you be dumping
your mask on july the 20th
well like many people i want to get away
from these restrictions as quickly as i
possibly can and we don't want them to
stay in place for a day longer
than is necessary we are going to i
think now move into a period
where there won't be legal restrictions
the state won't be telling you what to
do but you will want to exercise
a degree of personal responsibility and
judgment so different people will come
to different conclusions on things like
masks for example and the prime minister
will set out more detail on
the the national policy on some of those
restrictions in
the coming days but there will be things
that we all
definitely need to do as i say it will
be essential
that every adult gets fully vaccinated
and there are still people
in the most significant categories
categories 1 to 9
who haven't been vaccinated 50 000
people in those categories got
vaccinated
in the last week they've come forward
relatively late in the process but
it's really important that we get those
remaining people
vaccinated it will also be important
that we do things like
making sure that the most vulnerable get
their flu vaccinations
this autumn and winter because that
would be a big issue there will be
things we need to do as a society
to make sure that we keep through we get
through this but before we
before we go on to that can we just deal
with a question i asked you
if you are permitted will you
be getting rid of your mask i i will i i
don't
particularly want to wear a mask i don't
think
a lot of people uh enjoy doing it
we will be moving into a phase though
where these will be matters of personal
choice
and so some member society will want to
do so
for perfectly legitimate reasons but it
will be a different
period where we as private citizens
make these judgments rather than the
government telling you what to do
okay now apparently today is national
thank you day whose idea was that and
um what would you the government like
nation to be doing once they stopped
watching this program
well it was actually a bottom-up idea it
came from local communities
uh they came together and established
this idea that
this is a moment in which we can all go
and say a big thank you to those who've
helped us
in our daily lives over the course of
the last year perhaps those people
who've gone out of their
way to support the community through
covert 19 or others
who've done good work the prime minister
will be hosting
some of those who've helped us through
the pandemic at number 10
and i know people in my own community
that i would like to say
a big thank you to isn't this a bit
previous
you've just advised me to wait for the
prime minister's
statement on july the 19th but you're
encouraging everybody to
barbecue today i mean couldn't this have
waited a couple of weeks until
we actually know what the guidance is
going to be
isn't this yet another case of the
government sending mixed messages
no the government didn't create uh the
actual thank you day it's actually been
created by members
you didn't have to back it today we can
say thank you anytime in the next
six months if we want to well to say the
government didn't create
this day it's been created by mems the
public who themselves wanted to say
thank you of course uh there are
guidelines in place that you have to
follow if you're
holding an event today and i'm sure the
prime minister and others who
who are doing so will make sure that
they are followed but the point of the
day
uh is for those of us who benefited from
the hard work and compassion empathy
that others have provided over the
course of last year
to reach out to them and say thank you
and that can be done in many ways
there may be some people who are holding
socially distanced get-togethers
but there'll be plenty of other people
who might use this opportunity simply to
pick up the phone to somebody
who's done good work and really help
them out over the course of the last
year
yes indeed we can say thank you in many
ways wouldn't one way
be for the health secretary or the prime
minister
to pick up the phone to the let's say
the royal college of nursing or the bma
and say you know what we decided that
one percent
pay rise which is below inflation is
going to be boosted
by two or three percent that would be a
real way to say thank you wouldn't it
well we all want to reward those people
who've worked in the nhs and social
carers local government secretary
i feel very strongly about that that at
the moment is a topic for the
independent pay review body
who will be providing advice to the
health secretary
and the government in the coming months
and armed with that
we'll make a decision but it's only in
my role i've always
driven to provide local government with
the resource it needs
to fund social care we've done that over
the course of the pandemic we've now
done it
with two record-breaking settlements for
the local government sector since boris
johnson became
prime minister and i very much hope will
be in a position to do that in the
future
so uh we're not stuck to the one percent
it could be higher in the end
well the process is that uh the
recommendation
is judged by the independent pay review
body and then it comes to ministers for
a final
decision so nothing is is set in stone
but we as ministers will have to wait
for the advice that we receive from the
pay review body and that's the right
thing to do
right well let's keep talking about how
we say thank you you say in your release
that you want to thank people who have
provided refuge with women
facing domestic abuse which everybody
agrees
has risen during lockdown so
now women who are afraid to venture out
onto the high street
in case they run into their abusers are
being urged
to rock up today to a cheery barbecue
whilst having nowhere to go
later because of lack of funds for
refugees now that would be a good way of
saying thank you and that's i think
that's in your bailiwick isn't it
why not say thank you today with some
more money
for domestic abuse refuges for the women
who have suffered violence
well trevor we are doing that we passed
the domestic abuse act
earlier in the year which is a landmark
piece of legislation
to ensure that women and men who are
victims of domestic abuse
get the support that they need in safe
and secure accommodation
such as refuges we've fully funded that
major commitment
with 125 million pounds and that money
is now with local councils
who are ensuring that local services get
the support that they need and in fact i
spoke
last week at the women's aid conference
to the brilliant people who run those
refuges
across the country to say thank you to
them and also
wrote to every local council in the
country urging them
to use that money wisely and amongst
other services that they commission
to make sure that they properly fund
women's refuges
because they do a fantastic job they
have often been funded in quite a
hand-to-mouth way
in recent decades that needs to come to
an end now that we've got this very
significant amount
of extra funding available for them did
the leaders of women's aid read out to
you what they said in their report a
couple of months ago
which is uh the 90 million announced in
the budget
today is not enough they then go on to
say
that they need 393 million
pounds for of funding and that there is
a shortfall of 200 million pounds
in the government's current plans
what are you going to do about that well
i i don't recognize those numbers
they're not ones i've actually seen
the the amount of funding the amount of
funding i'm reading it out to you
i understand that but the amount of
money that we've provided 125 million
pounds
is actually considered to be fully
funding
the refuge and domestic abuse
uh duties that now fall on local houses
but not by women's
aid well i had a i had very good
conversation with
the chief executive women's aide and
with representatives
of those who run refuges during the week
they appreciate the funding of course
people would always like to have
more money but this is a very
significant increase in the amount of
funding
that any government has given in the
past for women's refugees and for other
services they'll be provided
for victims of domestic abuse the key
thing now
is to make sure that councils perform
their duties
under this new piece of legislation
correctly and they include
giving women and other victims of
domestic abuse priority
for social housing if they need to leave
their home
ensuring that they get the support
services that they need that can be
delivered in many different settings and
as i say making sure that refuges
across the country are put on a
sustainable financial footing
so we don't see the situation that i'm
afraid we have done in the past
which is where some of those refugees
are having to kind of survive
year in year out with too little money
and not
long-term sustainable funding we're
going to change that
well perhaps you need to have another
conversation with them but let's let's
talk about um
battley and spent um you lost when you
might have won do you blame matt hancock
well of course i'm disappointed that we
lost we had a great candidate ryan
stevens and i'd love to have seen him
in parliament but governments very very
rarely take
seats off oppositions in by-elections in
fact there's only been one
instance in recent years which was
hartley paul which was an exceptional
result actually this was the biggest
swing
from an opposition to the party of
government
for 39 years so in my lifetime
so it was still a fantastic result for
the conservative party albeit not
exactly what we would have hoped for um
and i think there are a lot of questions
for kierstarma as to how the labour
party
are just scraping home by 300 or so
votes
when they should be romping home in
these sorts of elections
okay well um here's a question for you
um
given that you had a 8 000 vote leg up
from
george galloway who took votes from
labour
actually it wasn't that good a result
for you and surely there's something
more fundamental going on here as there
was in cheshire
and amisham could it be that like in
cheshire many people in those
very pretty villages uh around batley
think that your planning reforms mean
that
your idea of leveling up is allowing
developers to concrete
over their villages and fields
no i don't agree with that at all i mean
on the question of
the by-elections as i say governments
extremely rarely take seats off
the opposition in by-elections of course
it was also disappointing result in
cheshire and amisham
but the argument put out there very
disingenuously
by the lib dems that there were huge
amounts of houses being built in that
area
uh was simply untrue last year only a
hundred houses
were built in the cheshire amisham
constituency which i think was the
tenth lowest of any local authority in
the whole country
what we want to see are good quality
environmentally sustainable homes with
the infrastructure around them
being built across the country so that
young people and families can get onto
the housing ladder
that's absolutely critical to levelling
up to
tackling intergenerational unfairnesses
in this country
and we're going to redouble our efforts
to build those homes but do so in a way
that protects green spaces
they won't be being built on the green
belt and we want to make a planning
system
which is much more engaging than the
current one in which only one or two
percent
of the public have any contact with in
their lifetimes
when we're talking about um leveling up
on friday you were in a place called
kidsgrove which is near stoke on trent
you were talking about the importance of
the investments that you're making
locally and you tweeted leveling up in
action
where 20 17 million pounds of investment
from the towns fund
has enabled the reopening of the sport
center
there in kidsgrove um would it not have
been
simpler if the conservative-led
staffordshire county council hadn't
withdrawn their substitute subsidy in
2017
to that sports center in the first place
then you wouldn't have had to make that
investment
well the towns fund is part of our now
almost 10 billion pound investment into
towns and smaller cities across the
country
aimed to improve living standards
improve quality of life
and i was really pleased to go to to
kidsgrove by stoke on trent
as you say on friday and see how it's
impacting people's lives
there the decision actually was taken by
a labour council
there it was very unfortunate as a
result of the town's fund we're changing
that
and that sports centre is being brought
back into community use
as we speak and i'm hoping that we'll be
able to do more things like that across
the country
particularly examples like that where
it's actually community
ownership that's a sports centre that's
going to be run by the local community
itself not by a council
but by a group of engaged local
residents coming together and we're
putting
funding available for those sorts of
schemes to happen right across the
country
one last very quick question if i may uh
mr generic
um last week was the fourth anniversary
of the awful events
at the grenfell tower and the government
has been making
quite a lot of money available to repair
cladding but the estimates uh
to deal with the range of
buildings across the country um
are as high as 15 billion pounds and
you've made about three and a half
billion pounds available
that means that many uh flat owners
across the country are having to pay and
we've seen
lots of um reports this week are having
to pay
the price of their entire properties
in order to repair the cladding that
surely cannot be right
well i have huge sympathy with those uh
leaseholders who are placed in an
impossible situation
the government is actually putting over
5 billion pounds
towards this issue we're ensuring that
the most dangerous material
acm cladding and other unsafe forms of
cladding are removed from all high-rise
buildings in the country
at no cost to leaseholders that work is
underway now we're making
good progress we're also
trying to ensure there's a much more
sensible and proportionate approach
to risk on other buildings particularly
the lower rise ones
because we are seeing examples of
leaseholders being asked to pay bills
for works which seem to be unnecessary
there's no actually higher risk of an
individual
living in a a purpose-built flat or a
high-rise building than in any other
building
in fact more people die in fires in
houses and bungalows
than they do in high-rise apartments so
we're working with lenders and insurers
and surveyors
to try to create a much more sensible
and proportionate way forward
mr generic thank you very much indeed